now also developing tonight in the
washington sewer in swamp democrats
continue to try and ram through their
far left socialist 3.5 trillion dollar
wish list but get this democrats
infighting showing no signs of slowing
down senators mansion and cinema say
well they're not on board with the
multi-trillion dollar reconciliation
package now while senator sanders is now
suggesting that he's a no vote on the
infrastructure deal if it's not
accompanied by the reconciliation
package and just wants you know what do
they want here 3.5 trillion dollars on
top of all the other money they've
already spent you know free community
college for illegal immigrants more
green new deal special interest
giveaways electric this electric that
universal pre-k corporate capital gains
tax cut height tax hikes you will pay
for that government-funded child care
great they already mess our kids up in
public schools so many places now we're
going to indoctrinate the more more paid
leave extending obamacare a major boost
to irs funding so all of us can be
audited every year not just me and biden
is still bizarrely trying to claim that
reckless spending plans actually cost
quote zero dollars okay joe sounds like
you're using the old style abacus that
you were trained on we actually today
have something called a calculator
simple math joe you don't need to go to
mit to figure it out anyway meanwhile
biden continues to rely on barack obama
to sell his destructive agenda who told
abc the country desperately needs the
trillions and trillions in new spending
here with reaction author of a brand new
book for such a time as this outnumbered
co-host kaylee mcenany as well as fox
news contributor joe concha i don't know
i look at the trillions of dollars joe
and you know what i see you should have
your own show on media uh
i see yeah the new green deal radicals
running the entire democratic party and
they're even telling nancy pelosi nope
she wanted to vote on the infrastructure
bill she said they said no deal so now
the whole is in disarray and who knows
what mansion and cinema will do in the
senate
that's the thing right if this thing
fails it will be democrats that
ultimately put it in the ground sean and
look if spending billions for programs
like tree equity that's billions with a
b then providing free college for those
who aren't legally in this country
isn't much of a stretch and let's take
the spin out of this okay you look at
the committee for a responsible federal
budget and they look at the numbers
without spin and they say this 3.5
trillion dollar bill would call for the
us government to borrow one trillion
dollars they also say it would have
three trillion added to the national
debt over 10 years that's back breaking
stuff and they also say the price tag is
really actually 5.2 wait a minute
obvious gimmicks go ahead they said that
this isn't going to cost us a penny
won't cost us one cent
hence my point right this is going to
cost us a lot even the washington post
fact checker called the president's zero
dollar claim quote mythical zero and
said that the president whoever writes
mr biden's scripts was being misleading
on this and this kind of fourth grade
messaging sean it's going to put this
bill at serious risk because in the
court of public opinion this is getting
laughed out of the room either way to
your point this bill is either tanked by
the squad aoc wing of the party who
promised to tank it moderate the
so-called human infrastructure bill or
moderates right
mansion and cinnamon it only takes one
it's hard to see how this bill becomes
reality and the irony is again democrats
will only have themselves to blame in a
civil war that is only getting worse
okay so kaylee now it's a question
republicans ought to do donald trump
gave the republican party let's be
honest uh a shot of adrenaline a spine a
backbone and he showed people how to
fight
and you know what it's uh it's not
beanball right it's a blood sport as
they call it in washington so my
question is republicans now they're out
of the process they're not being
included at all democrats now are facing
a debt ceiling problem they have control
of the house the senate and the white
house so i don't think any republicans
should lift a finger to help them raise
the debt limit so they can waste all
that money that they say is free
sean you're exactly right but here's the
reality that we all know you will have
nancy pelosi chuck schumer joe biden
trying to blame a lack of raising the
debt ceiling or the shutting down of the
government on republicans it is
nonsensical it would be confounding
because guess who runs all both branches
the house uh the senate you know the
legislative branch and the executive
branch it's democrats but they're
already trying to blame this on
republicans so republicans to your point
sean need to have a spine need to stand
up say this is categorically on
democrats if this doesn't pass it's
because of either aoc uh and rashida
talib or the you know the far left flank
or it's because of cinema and mansion
tanking it it's one of the two democrat
flanks it is categorically not
republicans they will try to blame it
however on the right as they always do
let's play a little john mclaughlin
predictions does it pass joe concha
molton it does not pass whatsoever
[Laughter]
i gotta say democrats always stick
together they do so they do have that
one attribute i think it'll pass eleanor
clift next uh
all right we're done thank you
exactly exactly jack german now we're
really going back in time you just aged
all of us except kaylee who doesn't know
who we're talking about hopefully hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else